hey before i start this i'm going to ask
you to uh hit the like button comment
below and if you feel so inclined uh
share this with your friends as what i'm
about to discuss is probably more
important than anything else i've
uh
really ever covered in relation to this
channel
this show
and this movement now i know that many
of you were expecting um
this show to come back here to youtube
today and uh yes uh the suspension from
the channel
has been removed so we can stream again
but the strike is still on for another
month so uh in constantly being attacked
by youtube for
not actual guideline violations uh with
the constant creation rather of new
guidelines and rules i've actually asked
youtube to clarify their attorney's
recent comments and we'll give them uh
one more week to respond in the interim
you can still watch the show live every
day on rumble or the full extended show
uh on mug club it's like another 45
minutes to an hour every day but uh
today i've decided to do something
different here that i've never done
before and that's to issue uh
a mission statement
i guess
little jerry maguire asked i want to
explain to you
really why this show is what it is why
it matters so much to me
to create this show for you
um why we provide the references the
sourcing that we do why we walk the kind
of tightrope that we do why there are so
few sponsors on this show and
important for me why
louder with crowder is the only daily
show
um that i will ever create
in my life and and just to be clear this
video is going to be just as much about
you
as it is
me and my team how grateful i am for you
and how many
um there are out there
just like
you and how we can fight like hell for
you and more importantly hopefully
before this is over uh how i can help
you do it for yourself
so this is one video
to make clear without any confusion as
to what i we
and you our supporters
are all about here at louder with
crowder so to address youtube on the
outset okay
my goal
is not to get banned from youtube it's
never to be uh it's never been rather to
be banned from youtube it's merely to
understand the rules
of youtube here so that
we know how to abide by them and we can
plan the content
accordingly content that maybe we know
would be in violation of youtube's
ever-changing guidelines policies
advertiser friendly borderline insert
your guess is as good as mine here so
that we can put that content exclusively
uh on mug club in order for you the
viewer to to get the best of both worlds
you know sometimes people say well i
don't want to see why are conservatives
still on youtube why don't you create
your own and then some people say well
you need to reach the unreached and
that's true
the way for us to do both is to
understand the rules of the sandbox on
youtube which are never clear and to
create a space
where all of us can be together
regardless of those now what do i mean
by the best of both worlds um that
brings me to content
uh what is it that we strive to do here
with our content i can tell you right
off the bat um let me give you the how
and then i'll circle back to the why
one is to be the most transparent show
that there is so to provide all
references all sources to consistently
be accurate and to consistently be
correct so that we can focus on uh
comedy and entertainment this is this is
a comedy show we aim to be an anti-bully
to punch up
against the hard-left media
establishment and to give everyone else
like you
a fighting chance if there's an
all-powerful group out there that you're
not allowed to discuss uh
we will insult it if there's something
that's been swept under the rug we'll
lift it if a subject is cloaked in
darkness we shine a light on it if
there's a sacred cow we burn it and we
aim to do that of course while being
sensitive to everyone's differences
proclivities and disabilities you'll
notice uh i've even hired an interpreter
for the hearing impaired
another goal is to always end the show
uh providing you with some kind of a
solution this is something that
is frustrating and is not a part of the
design of a lot of content out there
it's really easy to be a john oliver or
seth meyers and just [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] without putting any skin in
the game as to how to fix it and i'm not
just talking policy or politics so
sometimes
in the case of having a legislator or a
senator or a congressman on the show
that'll be a component of it more so
offering solutions every single show
is a component of what we do as to how
and what you can do in your private life
um now to be clear this is heresy in the
media
little little history do you know the
reason that this show exists is because
every single major cable news player
told me it would never work
that you
you
the viewer the supporter
you don't exist
um
they told me that making a right leaning
show
that would have come wouldn't work i'd
have to cut out all the comedy boil it
down to red meat catch phrases bumper
sticker slogans and to target
specifically a 65 and older demographic
do you know the reason that changed my
mind exists is because that segment was
turned down
by every major producer i'd ever
approached any even more in book form
was declined by every major conservative
publisher that i'd spoken with again i
was told that you
the market for it as they know the
viewer
didn't exist you don't exist and so i
had to step out in faith and and believe
that those in power and this is just as
much on on the right
of the media industry as the left i had
to step out in faith believe that those
in power were wrong believe
that the millions of you who now tune in
actually did exist
i just i to step out in faith and find
you
and i can't i'm so glad
that i did it
had it never been done um
and they said it couldn't be done uh
that you didn't exist i will say it's
been one of my life's greatest joys to
have proven
that they were wrong
that there are more of us out there that
there are more of you out there
and that we're stronger together
especially when we
fight like hell and here at louder with
crowder as far as the content
this is something i want to sort of
you know give you a little bit of inside
baseball i've always had three criteria
uh which a story a segment or a show has
to meet
this has always been the case behind the
scenes but you may not know it uh as the
audience and i i want you to understand
it um the three criteria is that any
content on this show must
be a informative be entertaining or c
enlightening at least two of those three
ideally all three what do i mean by that
okay informative uh this means
the content our content must be
informing you must be providing you uh
with new accurate information that you
don't already have so examples would be
when we break news when we do hidden
camera segments or things like change my
mind things that nobody else has so we
are bringing new information to the
table that's informing you entertaining
seems pretty self-explanatory this is an
entertainment show look
i'm a comedian dave is a comedian the
content must always it's got to always
be entertaining or we're not doing our
job period okay then enlightening this
one's a little i hate to use the word
nuance but uh
what this means is
if we're going to cover information that
you already know
in other words something that is
unoriginal but is still important to you
breaking news for example then we better
shine a new light on it we better bring
some new information or insight to the
table an example of this would be
election night look
okay everyone and their dog was covering
election night
i we were not creating any new
information but more of you tuned into
this program on election night
than any other single show in all of
cable news or standard news
because we provided
hopefully enlightening information for
example when everyone else called
arizona we we said um
there's some info coming out of there
that uh
maybe they're not telling you that we're
concerned about
uh when local detroit affiliates were
calling wayne county for trump we were
talking about that live broadcasting it
nationally which is also why it was so
surprising when it was later declared
nationally for biden that was a night
where every show started with the same
raw material and our goal was to provide
you with something different something
enlightening and i cannot tell you how
much i appreciate
you for choosing to vote for us with
your viewership which brings me to an
important point
look we don't want this to be your only
show
that's never a good thing you should
vary your your sources your information
but we do want to be your most familiar
i want to be the one you feel most
comfortable with and watch the most
consistently regardless of the news
cycle and today's news cycle that's a
whole other problem it's a game we don't
play
that's a huge part of this mission
statement now what do i mean by that
okay i've worked in cable news in the
past
for years over half a decade and before
this generation to give you context out
there every single one of your parents
grandparents great grant whatever it is
they only had about a half hour of news
a day
two times a day maybe three times a day
there was not a 24-hour news cycle
so now regardless of whether there is
news to cover if there isn't enough to
fill a 24-hour cycle cable outlets
they have to kick in the outrage machine
on both sides they need to create
something to cover now this show in
contrast uh being once a day and an
entertainment show we don't have to do
that
and we never will
on slow news days those are the days
that sometimes we take our biggest
creative swings and
big creative and misses
because we don't have to fill the show
with useless crap and i'd rather you
leave informed happy and entertained
rather than fooled
and depressed and on the flip side look
when the world is going to hell in a
handbasket and there's too much news to
even cover and that does happen we want
to cover what matters most more
accurately than anyone else as the only
show that hopefully doesn't want to make
you blow your head off so here's an
analogy for you okay
if you exercise properly
anyone out there exercises or trains for
a sport more specifically training but
we'll use the term interchangeably if
you train properly you should leave the
gym
refreshed not exhausted now sure there
are of course exceptions there will be
heavy days there will be days where you
have to push it
but especially for those on mug club who
get the extended show where we spend
more time you know chatting with you and
interacting with you i i want you to
leave feeling better happier more
purpose-filled for having tuned in not
depleted
and hopeless and and that brings me to
something else that i really haven't
discussed uh here
and i usually don't like discussing but
is important
and that's sponsors
so
you may have noticed that i run very few
sponsorship spots
on this show compar compared to others
on average from the numbers uh we run
about one-tenth the sponsorship
placement
people in the industry are often stunned
and it is true i'd be a far richer man
if i did what all other shows do and to
be clear this is not a this is in no way
a condemnation
of any other program all other shows do
this one way we choose to do it
differently doesn't mean one of us is
right
it means that we have different goals i
can promise you that we will never run
more than one sponsorship one
advertisement per show
and that that spot will always be as
entertaining as we can make it as
as opposed to say
16 minutes of every hour when when this
was back on am radio in three hours once
a week why is that because in my opinion
if half or a quarter or a third
of any given show is advertising that
means what
that means you are the commodity
the advertiser is not being sold to you
you are being sold to them
and
because the mission of this show is not
to serve advertisers it is always to
serve you
i'll also only ever work with
advertisers who i believe truly do that
and if they don't i will drop them like
a bad habit you have my word i have and
i will and ironically this brings me to
another point of this show and that is
when talking about sponsorships
to help genuinely good businesses out
there who deserve it because in this era
of boycotting and bicoding i i get it i
get that it's important to know where
your dollar is going and i agree
i only want to partner with companies
who are either a
serving you something valuable something
that i think you guys might like need or
use or b
are aligned with or at the very least
never in opposition
to our values to your values uh and i i
do i promise that's what we'll we'll
always do i want this place to be a
microcosm
not to affect change in some nebulous
sort of this arbitrary way but in a real
tangible fashion
including in a financial way and look
i'm a self pretty self-deprecating guy
it's how i was raised uh it's part of
who i am and so
this is the only time you'll hear me do
it on the show i've never come out and
championed the numbers or the popularity
of this show in part because i'm
grateful and i understand that you could
all change your mind tomorrow
and in part because i just want the
content to speak for itself but
it is relevant here when discussing
supporting businesses
and how many of you are out there
so that you don't feel alone so i'll do
it once a lot of shows out there claim
to be you know the most popular
ex or the biggest conservative
whatever you know what i'm talking about
it's like roller coasters everyone
claims that theirs is the biggest the
fastest the best and then you find out
well that's really only for wooden
roller coasters and that's for inverted
that's
okay
as far as advertising goes the
demographic that really matters is 18 to
49 year olds 18 to 50 something year
olds depending on who you ask and that
is
you
the viewer of this show in this industry
i want you to know this is the reason
that i discuss these numbers here today
you
listening watching at home
uh maybe on your tv
baby in your truck it better be on audio
you
hold the cards
this show is
number one not only in the
right leaning
uh as far as the demographic of you
but even in comparison to every single
network comedy show in the demographic
you
period it's not even close there are
more of you viewers and listeners in
this demo who tune into this than any
other show of this kind that exists
there isn't even a distant second period
now i we have been blessed with that
um
blessed with
what i consider
incredible influence and opportunity by
the good graces of you
and as much as
we do some really silly stuff granted i
don't take that i don't take that part
lightly and and finally and this is
i would say personally
possibly the most important
because of how much you
uh mean to me
person watching listening to this show
this will be the only daily show
that i do for the rest of my life
you have my word on that now
what do i mean by that okay half of the
other
hosts out there very very talented
unbelievable many of them are my good
friends
they'll host on average like two and a
half shows a day maybe two or three
hours on radio then 44 minutes on
television sometimes a separate podcast
they're even hosted do like three
simultaneous podcasts on a given day or
in a week and to me it just ends up
being the same show it just ends up
being
a deluded version of the same show and i
know how this business works uh i've
been offered other shows
full disclosure i also know that i
cannot pour everything that i have
everything about me that matters into
two or three different shows but i can
make one show
the best show it can possibly be
for you now maybe other people and
granted this this is probably the case
maybe they're not like this maybe it's
my adhd brain whatever it is but again
my goal is to serve you and i've always
felt that i owe it to you to create the
best show humanly possible especially
because so many of you have voted with
your dollar to join uh mug club and and
really keep this show afloat not funded
by a foreign caliphate
not making money on youtube as it is
entirely
because of you like pbs says viewers
like you and then they get federal
grants no this is entirely kept afloat
even those who watch the free show the
free show is entirely kept alive by the
people who join mug club that's it
and a few sponsors here and there
so it's it's also i want to be clear
that's why mug club is not just an
extended segment
um
but it's almost an entire it actually is
it's an entire extra show with games
multimedia we do some chats but really
some of the most valuable content that
could never be broadcast
on youtube it's not thanks for the
patreon ding why because i promised you
the best show that i can create and i
know i wouldn't be able to look myself
in the mirror and say that i've done
that if i spread myself across three
different networks three different shows
i can't do it this
show will always be
my show with 100
of my focus on you i will throw myself
with all the velocity i can generate
into this singular program every day
until i'm so spent
that i retire and pass the torch
hopefully to someone else and anything
anything that interferes with or
compromises that
will be
excluded
because you
need
to be a priority you i want to see you
alongside me fighting like hell i want
to see you
coming up with solutions i want to see
you
helping other people and pass your torch
this
is my promise
that's our mission statement and that is
how i
we with you
all fight like hell
all right well i just shot the uh the
spartan plate
with this uh this walther um patriot is
actually it's a limited edition firearm
you know sometimes you sort of think
okay when it's something that's that's
nicer that's a little
a little more showy
which is atypical for me you think
okay
it'll shoot good enough
surprisingly pleasant uh to shoot and
and really ergonomic because you know
i'm used to the walther uh ppq five the
polymer i have one of those uh but this
is all steel so it changes the dynamics
a little bit
it's really nice uh
so let's take a few more shots
just for youtube
swap me out for uh
like a like a woman in a bikini
that does that does well
i get a feel for it again everything
there's always something a little new
so
could be worse
could be better could be worse you had
some direction
oh come on it's really close but
it's not bad
[Music]
[Music]
be
[Music]
yes
[Music]